hey everyone welcome back my name is
nehul and in this video we'll be taking
a look at differences between graphql
and rest api so these are very common
two things two topics which are often
raised as a question by a lot of people
who are new
to web development and web programming
so i'm gonna be settling this debate in
what is what and what you should use in
today's time let's go also if you're new
here make sure you like and subscribe to
the video to keep watching such content
i'm gonna be creating a lot more content
in the future so make sure you are
subscribed and hit the bell icon to
receive all these updates so the first
thing we have to take a look at is this
rest api what this rest is res stands
for representational state transfer and
what this is is that it is broadly a
convention how communication should
happen over http now what do i mean by
that that means let's say you have an
endpoint which is slash api slash user
right now
this is just a convention i'm just
making this up right now so if i have a
get request on api
slash user with a parameter of id is
equal to 2 for example this might have a
convention of returning me that user
right if you read this it
almost seems like that this should
return a user if i have a post request
to this or maybe a put request for
example
then this end point right here if
included in the body let's say in the
body i have included some user details
you would probably wonder or you know
think that this would create the user
right if i have a patch request for
example and these are different http
method names right these are different
http method names if i have a patch
request you would probably consider that
this is an edit to the profile and if i
have a delete request then it probably
makes sense that this is
going to delete the user right now the
funny thing about the rest api is that
all of them
all of them are conventions that means
you can write back in specific code
which when sent as a delete request
actually creates that user right so you
can post a delete request which creates
that user so why is that i mean why then
even have so many methods because like i
said rest is a convention it says that
hey
people
whenever you're trying to delete a
resource from the server although you
can use post in most of the cases but we
also have a dedicated method available
to us and this method is nothing it's
just a you know request method which you
send at least in the fetch request by
just writing the method name so whatever
method you write here instead of a http
fetch request gets sent to the server
right there are some limitations here
for example in case of kit you cannot
have this body which i was talking about
right so it's not like they are
completely irrelevant that you can
pretty much use anything at any other
place there are certain limitations but
for the most part you will see you can
interchange post and patch for example
put and patch delete and post and you
will pretty much get the similar result
rest also has a concept of called this
concept called status codes so the
status codes what this is is that it's
just a number denoting if the request
was successful or not so the client says
what it wants to do via method of the
request right so the available methods
we have we have a bunch of methods i'm
just writing the most common one get
post
put patch
and so on the status quotes which we
have are a lot right so there are status
codes in the range of 100 100 or you
know commonly denoted as 1 0x for
example then we have status codes
like 200 which is the most common one
200 okay then we have status quotes in
200 range we have in 300 range which is
mostly associated with the redirects 400
range which is like a client error like
unauthorized or 404 not found stuff like
this and also in the 500 range which is
server error that means that server has
failed now like i said
i'm just saying these stuff i'm just
making this up i'm just saying that 400
is client error i'm just saying that 500
is server error i'm just saying that 200
is successful response but technically
speaking you can you may as well return
a 502 from your backend even if your
resource was successfully executed or
created or whatever you can return a 404
even if you do found the resource on the
server and do return the correct page
you can return 200 okay even if your
server crashed
you can't do all of that so what is the
point of this and what is the point of
this like i said again this is a
convention a convention to tell browsers
a convention to tell users that
something wrong has happened for example
a browser for a browser it does not make
sense to cache a 404 response right
inside a browser so chrome would
probably see i'm not sure like if
caching is implemented like this i'm
just giving you an example a random
example but yeah i mean probably chrome
would retry the four zero four or five
zero two error compared to a 200 okay
right so this is just a convention to
convey meaning to browsers and users
which as a developer you should always
follow but it's not necessary i mean you
can break the rules and you won't still
break the web okay graphql graphql is
the cool kid
in the town and people get confused a
lot when they say should i choose a rest
should i choose graphql should i you
know if is is the rest dead because of
graphql which is funny because graphql
actually operates on one rest end point
so rest like i said is just an
architecture just a practice you should
follow but graphql is a bit more than
that why because graphql is an actual
software is an actual piece of code
which runs on your server sure in case
of rest you are also running a server
but in case of graphql you are actually
running graphql code on top of a server
so what you do usually is you assign an
endpoint and again usually called
graphql graph graphql to a piece of code
this piece of code some some code i'm
i'm just going to create a database i
can but this is actually a software and
the software right here is a graphql
server right so what this server does is
that this takes this end point and
whatever you send here from client side
let's assume this is just some random
data it will try to convert the software
will try to convert this response into a
map
of data which it needs to collect and
then send it back to the client now hear
me out what does this mean so first you
have to understand in order to
understand this is first you have to
understand what the client says from the
client side so what client says in case
of graphql are basically two things a
query and a mutation right in case of
rest api remember what the client says
can pretty much be anything it could be
a json it could be some binary data it
could be anything in case of graphql
server there is a fixed thing which
clients have to say and that is the
first one is query and the second one is
mutation again this is a convention that
what should be what right just like http
status codes are convention this is also
a convention that what should be what
but ideally the convention is that
queries
should be a call to the back end which
does not mutate the data in any way
whether it's on database whether it's on
some remote api endpoint or anything so
if you want to retrieve let's say a user
record you will write a query
something like query user then get
user and then pass an id of one then for
example write name and that's it so what
you see right here what i have written
here is actually a string right so don't
confuse it with an actual sql query or
anything this is actually a string
passed on to the back end which is this
one
through post request
a rest api method on slash graphql a
rest api endpoint right and this is
passed as a string this string this
string right here is gone you know it's
put into this graphql server and what
this graphql server spits out
is a you know a graph of how it has to
get that information now you won't dive
deep into the details of how everything
works but what you have to realize is
that every single query which you write
here for example get user right or you
know if we have a mutation we'll take a
look at mutation soon but in this case
get user for example has a function
defined
right so async function get user on back
end so there's a function defined
somewhere on the back end which executes
this whole part and whatever you return
from here is returned
to the front end
right
so this this piece of code exists some
somewhere on the server right which has
the same name as what you have written
right here inside of the query okay so
now you might ask me then what's the
difference i mean this is the scene just
seems like some additional work over
rest api right and that's where you're
wrong because you can return let's say
you return an object here with a name as
mehul
right and then h as 22 for example but
if i only request name here you can see
in the query if i only request name from
the client side i'm only gonna get this
part from the http request right itself
which is this request so this age part
will never be even delivered to the
front end right so it saves you a lot of
data transfer it saves you a lot of
bandwidth on the front end and gives you
selective access to the fields which you
want which is super critical and super i
mean important as well for example let's
say if you had a rest api endpoint which
returned the name of the user so if you
had api user and then you know id for
example so if it just returned you name
and you wanted to have a name and an age
for example and you also want to
maintain this endpoint then you probably
have to create another endpoint or if
you want to have more data returned then
you probably have to create more
endpoints why because that one endpoint
which was actually using name might not
need age right but with graphql you can
be selective on the client side so it's
almost like writing a sql query on the
client side but getting it selectively
from the server now this is one of the
many benefits many many benefits of
graphql another benefit which i
personally like a lot is that graphql is
schema based that means you have to very
strictly define what goes to the server
that means this id argument can go to
the server and you have to strictly
define what can leave the server right
so if you have only defined that hey
only name is allowed age is not allowed
even if you return here h and request
age here graphql schema because it sees
that hey only name is allowed to go back
from server to client it will stop the
age variable right it will stop the age
variable from going and it will throw an
actual error so schemas are super
powerful for security point of view
as well as avoiding bugs while
developing um as well so schemas is a
beautiful feature of graphql of course
having a graph to traverse the data is
also beautiful because now in this case
i mean it doesn't make sense to nest
anything but you could probably you
would have seen a very popular example
like book
then an author then for example authors
books more books so you can nest these
queries like this and this will actually
give you i mean if your resolvers are
set up correctly it will actually give
you
the correct output on this let's quickly
take a look at mutations as well because
we did not cover that like i said
mutation is pretty much just a
convention queries and mutations they
pretty much only call a single resolver
these functions which i said are called
resolvers right so calling it a function
or a resolver is one and the same thing
so let's say if i have a mutation of
create user right so like i said you
right now there is a function called
create user
somewhere existing on the back end right
and whenever you call this create user
mutation this function gets executed
let's say you're calling it with a with
a name of mayhew and an id or whatever
right and then you return just say that
hey just give me status of this so what
the convention is it's basically nothing
right it's basically nothing it'll just
go ahead take this up find it in a
mutation resolver and see that if it can
execute this right so once it fights
that it executes that returns the
response and gets with the work right so
now you might see why this is a
convention again i don't know exactly
but one of the reasons you can think of
is because queries can be cached by
graphql in a better way because it it is
kind of like a read operation so it's
probably suitable for caching in some
cases mutations are usually not cached
right until you want them to explicitly
because crud operations which involves
deletion and updation of data they
should i mean they should not be cached
right you don't want weird stuff
happening on your database so yeah
that's pretty much it for graphql versus
http and i wouldn't say that we have got
into details of both of them actually
in much detail because http rest
architecture is super super broad in
terms of how browsers handle different
responses how the caching works on a
http request and you know this this sort
of thing and we haven't obviously gone
into any detail at all for graphql how
the query resolves works what are types
what is schema what are the valid return
types and stuff like this so maybe that
deserves a coding tutorial an actual
tutorial on its own but i believe this
will give you a solid framework of
understanding of how graphql and http
differ and if you're wondering like
which one should you use you should
always start with the rest that is you
know your standard apis get post put
patch you should try to use graphql if
you're riding a medium plus size app but
for the most applications graphql is
just simply an overkill because it will
keep you disciplined that's true that
you have to write all the schemas and
everything but it just becomes way too
much if you're just writing a login
application for example so start with
http if you think like you're trying to
create a big project then obviously you
can also start with graphql because that
will be a lot of discipline from the
start but yeah i mean that's that's
basically it both have their own place
in today's time and it's not like one is
killing another one so yep that's pretty
much it for this video if you learned
something make sure you leave a like
subscribe to the channel and hit the
bell icon that is all for this one i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]